I want you all to stay true to the most
real most sincere most authentic parts
of yourselves I want you to ask those
basic questions who do you want to be
what inspires you how do you want to
give back and then I want you to take a
deep breath and trust yourselves to
chart your own course and make your mark
on the world maybe it feels like you're
supposed to go to law school but what
you really want to do is teach little
kids maybe your parents are expecting
you to come back home after you graduate
but you're feeling a pull to travel the
world I want you to listen to those
thoughts I want you to act with both
your mind but also your heart and no
matter what path you choose I want you
to make sure it's you choosing it and
not someone else we learned about
dignity and decency that how hard you
work matters more than how much you make
that helping others means more than just
getting ahead of yourself we learned
about honesty and integrity that the
truth matters that you don't take
shortcuts or play by your own
[Applause]
doesn't kill unless you earn it fair and
square you just watched two amazing
clips of Michelle Obama take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]